IS IN GEORGIA REPUBLICAN
HERSCHEL WALKER CLOSING THE GAP
WITH HIS DEMOCRATIC OPPONENT,
SENATOR RAFAEL WARNOCK.
FIRST, HOWEVER, FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP ON THE TRAIL IN
IOWA, NOW MAKING HEADLINES NOT
ABOUT THESE MIDTERMS BUT HIS OWN
POLITICAL AMBITION.
CNN CHIEF NATIONAL AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT JEFF ZELENY ON THE
TRAIL IN SIOUX CITY WHERE WE ARE
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S POSSIBLE TIMELINE.
JEFF, WHAT DO WE KNOW?
>> Reporter: JIM, GOOD MORNING.
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
WAS HERE IN IOWA LAST NIGHT
KICKING OFF A SERIES OF RALLIES
GOING INTO ELECTION DAY AND WE
ARE NOW LEARNING THIS MORNING
THAT HIS TEAM IS EYEING THE WEEK
OF NOVEMBER 14th AS A POSSIBLE
TIME WHEN HE COULD ANNOUNCE A
THIRD BID FOR THE PRESIDENCY.
OF COURSE, ET CETERA' BEEN
HINTING AT THIS FOR WEEKS IF NOT
MONTHS.
HE'S BEEN PLANNING FOR THIS
BEHIND THE SCENES AND CLEARLY
WANTS TO RIDE WHAT THEY BELIEVE
IS GOING TO BE A REPUBLICAN WAVE
NEXT WEEK IN THE ELECTION.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE WEEK
BEFORE THANKSGIVING, POTENTIALLY
THE WEEK OF NOVEMBER 14th.
THIS IS ALL FLUID, AGAIN,
DEPENDING ON HOW NEXT WEEK'S
MIDTERMS GO.
BUT TAKE A LISTEN TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT LAST NIGHT HERE IN
IOWA AS HE FRAMED HIS DECISION
COMING UP.
>> IN ORDER TO MAKE OUR COUNTRY
SUCCESSFUL AND SAFE AND
GLORIOUS, I WILL VERY, VERY,
VERY PROBABLY DO IT AGAIN.
OKAY?
VERY, VERY, VERY PROBABLY.
THAT'S NICE.
WELL, GET READY, THAT'S ALL I'M
TELLING YOU, VERY SOON.
GET READY.
>> Reporter: SO THE QUESTION
REALLY COMING OUT OF THIS IS IF
HE WOULD ANNOUNCE IN NOVEMBER IS
THAT GOING TO ESSENTIALLY SCARE
OFF ANY REPUBLICAN CONTENDER?
IS THAT GOING TO CHANGE THE
MINDS OF ANY REALLY IN A LONG
LIST OF REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
EYEING A BID OF THEIR OWN LIKE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT MIKE
PENCE, FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS, FORMER U.N. AMBASSADOR
NIKKI HALEY.
THERE IS A LONG LIST OF PEOPLE
ALSO CONSIDERING A RUN.
WOULD PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RUN --
OR ANNOUNCEMENT, YOU KNOW, SORT
OF SLOW THE FIELD?
WE WILL SEE ABOUT THAT.
BUT, JIM, THIS WEEKEND VERY
INTERESTING, SUNDAY IN FLORIDA
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS HOSTING
A RALLY IN MIAMI, NOT INVITED
WAS FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS.
HE IS HOSTING A COMPETING RALLY
IN THE TAMPA BAY/ST. PETE AREA.
THE DYNAMIC BETWEEN THOSE TWO
CERTAINLY SOMETHING TO KEEP AN
EYE ON.
MARK YOUR CALENDAR POTENTIALLY
FOR THE WEEK OF NOVEMBER 14th
FOR A POTENTIAL THIRD BID FOR
THE PRESIDENCY.
NEVER MIND THE FACT ALL THE
INVESTIGATIONS AND OTHER THINGS
STILL LOOMING OUT THERE.
MR. TRUMP SOUNDED LAST NIGHT TO
ME LIKE HE IS GOING TO JUMP IN,